c'est très bien de le suspendre pourquoi
le supprimer définitivement non pourquoi
parce que c'est un outil pour lutter
contre l'épidémie si évidemment pour
venir l'épidémie bien sûr alors pourquoi
regardons les faits le tout d'abord
aujourd'hui bien sûr dans la
quasi-totalité des pays du monde
l'épidémie régresse mais ça n'a pas
disparu particules est-ce que alors par
contre une question à vous poser est ce
que l'épidémie régresse vraiment où est
ce que c'est parce qu'il ya une autre
actualité très très fort qu'on en parle
moins mais que l'épidémie est toujours
présente ça me fait
bizarre aussi bouillant c'est que c'est
vrai que depuis qu'il est plus
importante kako vide et que cette
épidémie on en parle beaucoup moins on a
l'impression que c'est fini que c'est
derrière nous c'est terminé donc non
mais si c'est vrai même si basse il s'en
fallait
quand même y aller
on en parlait et on a l'impression et
certains esprits étriqués sans doute
comme monsieur di vizio vont s'en servir
rte je te dis tu retires je retire que
tu te retires de
servir en disant voyez on n'en parle
plus parce que ce n'était rien pas du
tout halal et ça c'est la route des
médias norvégiens ont laissé tomber cet
acte odieux fabrice santoro pas la bride
sur ma question qu'est ce tu dis non mes
shows coiffure est question là non
d'abord la mienne cyril hanouna c'est
sur le fait que est ce qu affirme
également le co by dre grèce oui il
régresse c'est un fait oui on en parle
moins parce qu'une actualité sans doute
plus importante qui qui l'a chassé mais
ça c'est le propre de l'actuel mais
c'est pas les médias qui font l'épidémie
sans doute qu'effectivement il ya un
phénomène d'amplification c'est vrai qu
effectivement là sans doute que oui il y
avait fin de mon implication mais après
il ya une réalité il ya une réalité qui
est celle des chiffres il avait été qui
scelle décontamination il ya une réalité
bien après c'est de l'interprétation de
la réalité que nos médias ont sans doute
effectivement exagéré tout fabrice tu
penses qu'il fallait suspendre qu'on
peut suspendre ou aux bateaux supprimer
me demander ça à moi alors que depuis le
début je vous explique qu'il en fallait
un
cbg content je suis content d'en voir
j'avais un petit j'avais fait une
omelette norvégienne qui avait blessé
ici c'est comme ça tu me retrouve non
mais ce qui m'interpelle si vous voulez
soyons si on veut réfléchir 10 secondes
vous dit docteur dagerman que
effectivement c'est un outil pour lutter
contre l'épidémie oui essayé d'expliquer
ça oui tout à fait parce que pourquoi
l'épidémie très probablement risquerait
de revenir en automne en automne deux
c'est une année d'après la réserve et
d'inconscience le dieu ne m'a pas
transmis la donne
aujourd'hui à hong kong c'est en
nouvelle zélande et bien malheureusement
l'épidémie par ailleurs ces deux pays en
fassent vacciner 1 re confinement et
n'ya pas sexy quand ils pensent à
quel est l'intérêt du post bac simard et
c'est que l'ici
la vaccination malheureusement
risquerait d'être d'accablement j'ai
compris chez certaines personnes dont
l'idée fois qu'ils entrent évidemment il
est pas forcer les gens font vacciner de
fait doivent pas maximale en train de
retomber dans tetro bras pour objectif
de forcer les personnes à risque que
recevoir une dose éventuel alors de
protection est ce que je vous salue un
outil ça veut pas dire que ça valait
pour les utilisons très bonne nouvelle
vous ne laisserez sympa
aujourd'hui mais mais votre question
mais le professeur sur un point
effectivement avant le pass d'accès
n'est entrée en vigueur je crois le 23
janvier quelque chose comme ça arrive
même souffle à metz que pourriez nous
donner les statistiques de non vaccinés
s'il vous plaît en réanimation sur la
période du 20 au 31 janvier
non surtout pas surtout pas comme
effectivement factuellement est ce que
vous pourriez parce que c'est un outil
qui servait à forcer les gens à se faire
vacciner donc j'en déduis légitimement
que les personnes non vaccinées selon
les médias ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure et bien sont majoritaires en
réalisation oui c'est bien le cas ou
alors la brute dont on vous répond
pendant pendant la cinquième vague du dp
forte majorité donc depuis janvier oui
les personnes non vaccinées vous
représentez les trois quarts des
d'accord il y avait bien sûr son 1/4 de
patients vaccinés ou parfaitement
excusez moi
les médecins sais pas pourquoi pas
parce que si vous voulez moi j'ai une
excuse de l'assistance publique et
hôtellerie c'est un problème parce que
c'est à à l'assistance publique de paris
donc il ya une espèce de magma à paris
parce que moi j'ai donné de la drees
serait bien qu'ils adressent qu'elle
avoue didier effectivement le qui vous
dit quand même je fais parmi les 7500
aux hospitalisations en soi critiques en
france ouais mais nous vacciner donc
hospitalisé pour qu vide qui les perd 1
31% c'est l'adresse qui dit ça adresse
alors voilà quelle adresse ces chiffres
je ne m'avoue n'avait pas ses chiffres
mais si on a les boules et sur votre
disposition sur le site de l'adresse ça
s'écrit comme vous voyez on est pas
foutu
et là vous orienter le débat avait un
problème de vivre un nouveau toner dans
les bizarreries chaîne américaine e par
l'échec sa cravate a travaillé
longuement
non je suis tête à birmingham non merci
j'ai faim d'amour j'ai d'accra ils ont
bon je me suis contenté de lire ce
qu'apparemment cherche à faire et on
cale bolivie